Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I consider this one to be one of the most
influential papers in the field of light transport.
Normally, to create a photorealistic image,
we have to create a digital copy of a scene,
and simulate the paths of millions of light
rays between the camera and the light sources.
This is a very laborious task that usually
takes from minutes to hours on a complex scene,
noting that there are many well-known corner
cases that can take up to days as well.
As the rays of light can bounce around potentially
indefinitely, and if we add that realistic
materials and detailed scene geometry descriptions
are not easy to handle mathematically, it
is easy to see why this is a notoriously difficult
problem.
Simulating light transport in real time has
been an enduring problem and is still not
solved completely for every possible material
model and light transport effect.
However, Voxel Cone Tracing is as good of
a solution as one can wish for at the moment.
The original formulation of the problem is
continuous, which means that rays of light
can bounce around in infinitely many directions
and the entirety of this digital world is
considered to be a continuum.
If we look at the mathematical formulation,
we see infinities everywhere we look.
If you would like to learn more about this,
I am holding a Master-level course at the
Technical University of Vienna, the entirety
of which is available on YouTube.
As always, the link is available in the video
description for the more curious Fellow Scholars
out there.
If we try to approximate this continuous representation
with tiny tiny cubes, we get a version of
the problem that is much less complex, and
easier to tackle.
If we do this well, we can make it adaptive,
which means that these cubes are smaller where
there is a lot of information so we don't
lose out on many details.
This data structure we call a sparse voxel
octree.
For such a solution, mathematicians like to
say that this technique works on a discretized
version of the continuous problem.
And since we're solving a vastly simplified
version of the problem, the question is always
whether this way we can remain true to the
original solution.
And the results show beauty unlike anything
we've seen in computer game graphics.
Just look at this absolutely amazing footage.
Ice cream for my eyes.
And all this runs in real time on your consumer
graphics card.
Imagine this in the virtual reality applications
of the future.
My goodness.
I've chosen the absolute best profession.
Also, this technique maps really well to the
graphical card and is already implemented
in Unreal Engine 4 and NVIDIA has a framework,
GameWorks, where they are experimenting with
this in their project by the name VXGI.
I had a very pleasant visit at NVIDIA's GameWorks
lab in Switzerland not so long ago, friendly
greetings to all the great and fun people
in the team!
Some kinks still have to be worked out.
For instance, there are still issues with
light leaking through thin objects.
Beyond that, the implementation of this algorithm
contains a multitude of tiny little distinct
elements.
It is indeed true that many of the elements
are puzzle pieces that are interchangeable
and can be implemented in a number of different
ways, and that's likely one of the reasons
why NVIDIA and others are still preparing
their implementation for widespread industry
use.
Soon, we'll be able to solidify the details
some more and see what the best practices
are.
I cannot wait to see this technique appear
in the video games of the future.
Note that this, and future episodes will be
available in 4K resolution for a significant
bump in the visual quality of the series.
It takes a ton of resources to produce these
videos, but it's now possible through the
support of you Fellow Scholars on Patreon.
There is a more detailed write-up on that,
I've included it in the video description.
Thank you so much for supporting the show
throughout 2016, and looking forward to continuing
our journey together in 2017!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!